- [Narrator] Are these golf balls?
A science fiction set?
An alien invasion?
Nope, this is Bolwoningen,
and the only inhabitants here are humans.
(upbeat music)
Located in the Netherlands,
about an hour away from Amsterdam,
are 50 sphere houses made from cement
and reinforced with fiberglass.
Bolwoningen, which actually translates
to bowl, or bulb homes,
was built in 1984 by the
Dutch artist and sculptor,
Dries Kreijkamp.
It was created and supported by a subsidy
from the Dutch government for
experimental housing projects.
Inside the houses are three levels:
bedrooms on the ground,
bathroom on the middle,
and a living space on the top.
Although these homes
look out of this world,
their intention was to bring
its inhabitants closer to nature.
The round windows allow views
of the outside environment
from almost any angle.
And the complex itself
is positioned near a scenic canal.
The designer passed away in 2014;
however, his legacy lives on,
as these homes are still lived in today.
(upbeat music)